Thanks to CuriosityStream for supporting this
episode!
Go to CuriosityStream.com/microcosmos to start
streaming thousands of documentaries and non
fiction TV shows.
This frontonia is swimming in a minefield.
We can’t see all the dangers it’s evading,
but abruptly, the frontonia stops, and then
very, very slowly, begins to expand outward.
In this moment, the frontonia’s entire body
seems to shift away from its placid demeanor.
Gone is the swimming organism.
Now we have something more strained.
It’s like when a cat is staring off in the
distance with every muscle tensed and every
bit of fur standing on end.
You know just by looking that something is
causing distress, but the source of the terror
is invisible.
But still you keep looking, because you want
to know—
you have to know—
what has frozen this creature in alarm?
And why is it reacting this way?
The homalozoon we’re watching right now
has a lot in common with the frontonia we
were just observing.
Like Frontonia and most of the organisms we’ll
be talking about today, the homalozoon is
a ciliate, a single-celled organism marked
by the hair-like structures around its body.
But this homalozoon isn’t dealing with invisible
threats.
It is the threat, on the hunt for food.
And when it comes across this other ciliate,
a paramecium, the homalozoon has an invisible
weapon to help bring down its prey.
But instead, the homalozoon flinches from
the paramecium as if it has been stung, because
in a sense, it has been.
What we’ve just watched unfold is a battle
between extrusomes, a type of vesicle found
within single-celled organisms.
Within the cell, extrusomes usually take on
crystal-like structures or are housed in capsules.
But as we’ll see in a bit, when the time
comes to be used, extrusomes can be quite
dramatic to watch in action.
What I’ve just told you doesn’t reveal
much about an extrusome, though.
Is it an attack?
A defense?
Something else entirely?
Yes.
But more specifically, it depends.
Think of extrusomes sort of like a knife.
It can be a weapon, sure, but it can also
be used to feed or to craft.
It all depends on the nature of the blade
and the person wielding it.
Which is to say that there are a lot of different
types of knives in the world,
and also there are many types of extrusomes.
And while we cannot provide an exhaustive
display of all of the extrusomes known to
scientists right now, we can at least observe
a few of them.
Let’s start with the extrusome wielded by
our hungry homalozoon from earlier, which
is called a toxicyst because, it is
loaded with toxins.
We have seen toxicysts in action in various
ciliates throughout our journey through the
microcosmos, and perhaps our best view has
come from the dileptus.
All along that trunk-like structure are hundreds
of toxicysts.
And as the dileptus hunts for food, it sweeps
its trunk from side to side so that any prey
that comes in contact with the trunk will
also come in contact with those toxicysts.
For the ciliates that have them, the main
task of toxicysts is to help catch prey.
When not in use, they are stored
neatly within capsules, lying in wait.
But should an unsuspecting meal come too close,
predators like this lacrymaria will extend
their toxicysts out from their body and towards
their prey to paralyze it.
But look, different predators have different needs,
so their toxicysts may look different and
be wielded differently.
Some organisms might rely more on the paralytic
activity of the toxins, while others use the
toxicysts to physically hold onto their prey.
There are also extrusomes that are similar
to toxicysts, but not quite similar enough
to be grouped with them.
Like rhabdocysts, rod-shaped extrusomes found
on karyorelictid ciliates like this Trachelocercid,
that shoot like arrows into their prey.
And then there are suctorians, which look
very unassuming here.
They’re the round bodies sticking out from
a stalk in the middle of your screen right now.
As we change our perspective though, we can
start to make out the tentacles lining their bodies.
And among those tentacles are extrusomes called
haptocysts, which have a round knob at the end.
As unthreatening as suctorians appear, those
haptocysts were alble to grab ahold of some
unsuspecting creature that got too close.
Not only were the haptocysts able to puncture
the prey’s body, they were able to act as
a highway back to the predator, creating a
connection that ultimately feeds the suctorian.
But as we saw earlier, the homalozoon wielded
a toxicyst against the paramecium, but the
paramecium also had the ability to fight back.
The paramecium rely on a set
of extrusomes called trichocysts.
In this clip, James—our master of microscopes—has
added some diluted ethyl alcohol onto a slide.
The paramecia are trying to huddle in the
pockets of water where there’s less alcohol,
but as they come in contact with more and
more of the alcohol, they begin to release
their trichocysts.
It might be a little difficult to see, but
up close, with some patience and a careful
eye, you may be able to see it better.
Ignore the bubbles that are emerging from
the edge of the paramecium, apparently that's
something that can just happen as a paramecium
sits on the slide for a while.
But look around them, at the long threads
emerging from the side of the paramecium,
which seem to overwhelm the ciliate.
Paramecium and their trichocysts are perhaps
the best-studied extrusomes among all ciliates.
Unlike toxicysts, which are usually localized
to one part of the predator’s body, trichocysts
are usually found throughout the length of
the organism’s body.
But they do have special docking sites that
keep the trichocysts situated right below
the plasma membrane.
When a stimulus like a predator (or alcohol)
comes along, the membrane of the trichocyst
will begin to fuse with the paramecium’s
membrane, creating an opening from which the
trichocyst can discharge.
While paramecium have the best characterized
trichocysts of all, other species do have
trichocysts as well, including the frontonia
we showed you in the beginning of this episode.
In fact, we saw them in action, set off by
the cleaning chemicals that James had added
to the water.
He repeated this multiple times, adding drops
of this invisible danger so we can observe
the frontonia’s trichocysts.
Again and again, you can see how the cell
stops and seems instantaneously surrounded
by a mass of thin threads, similar in structure
to the paramecium’s trichocysts we saw earlier.
The extrusomes we’ve talked about so far
have clear roles in the eternal battle between
predator and prey.
Some defend, some attack.
But some extrusomes have a murkier purpose.
Like mucosyts.
We’re showing them here in euglena, which
are flagellates, but they’re found in ciliates
as well like loxophyllum.
They might be a way to get food, helping their
organisms create a sticky cell surface that
acts as a trap.
But they might also be a way to help the organism
build a cyst, a tool for movement.
Their exact purpose remains unclear, and who
knows, maybe they have a range of uses.
And with so many more types of extrusomes
that exist in the ciliate world, there are
so many opportunities for us to understand
more how these organisms interact
with the world around them.
These are all organelles perched along the
borders, an expression of hunger or a demand
for protection or something more mysterious,
waiting for a signal that says it’s their
time to eject out into the world.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
This episode has been brought to you by CuriosityStream,
a subscription streaming service that offers
thousands of documentaries and non­fiction
TV shows from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including award winning exclusives & originals.
They cover topics like history, nature, science,
food, technology, travel, and more!
And to round out our month of creepy things,
we’re going to recommend checking out The
Beasts of Halloween on Curiosity Stream.
Not only is it seasonally appropriate and
a bit creepy, but it is also educational!
You’ll dive into the world of superstitions
and traditions, and learn about the many animal
species that have become symbolic with the
scary and supernatural.
You can stream CuriosityStream’s library,
including their collections of curated programs
handpicked by their experts, to any device
for viewing anytime, anywhere, and if you
go to curiositystream.com/microcosmos and
use the code “Microcosmos” to sign up,
you’ll get 25% off for an entire year!
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who make it all happen
here at Journey to the Microcosmos.
The only reason this show exists is because
people want it to.
And these are some of those people.
If you'd like to see your name added to this
list and you know, I certainly would, you
can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.